You Slave You Lose
*clap clap*
You Slav You Lose
Youtube's favourite show everybody
No more you india you lose
You India you win
But you Slav you lose
You know why? cause
At least slavs can take a joke[VODKA]
WHY is he walking like that
Because he's drunk ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Come on Pюdepie
PPPFFFFFTTTTTT
Like everyone in Россия
Alcoholism, [al ka lism?]  it's a problem
WWWWOOOOOOOWWWWWWW
You know I actually met a lot of fans
Who come up to me like
I'm slav you know, I lose
¯\_(ツ)_/¯
It's okay, it's just a joke
Dont worry about it
it's just a joke
Remember to buy the merch *CYKA BLYAT*
LET'S just jump into it
I'm excited
It's been a long time.
This is from r/ANormalDayInRussia
[Background music]
Why is he just standing there?
Oh?
*chuckle*
oh..
what is happening?
*laughing*
Many questions, I have many questions
First off,
Why is that horse carriage connected to a car?
Second off...
Why is that man standing in the road?!
Third of all...
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?!
*Reading comment*
You Slav *clap*
You LOSE  *clap*
It's not just indian
That has a
deeper profound
skill of
Expressing their emotions and love
EEEEHHHHHHH
Russians also have a very romantic way to
GET IT ON
Kristina Gimme a BJ...
This really warms my heart
I must say.
A normal day in Russia everyone.
In other countries, they'll have a dog as a friend.
Why have a dog when
you can have a bear?
You'll never be depressed again!
AAAWWEEEE
This is so ... Sweet.
You slav you win? ლ(╹◡╹ლ)
Just another day in russia
(heh heh)
What is happening?
*sighs*
Silly russians!
There's no groceries there
Ugh
S.M.H.
*Desperate attempt at trying not to get demonetized*
MOVING ON
You EH you slav you lose
Everyone
*Wind in terrible phone mic*
A normal Lovely bike ride!
WOW
dat's nice
RUSSIAN AND ENGLISH AT THE SAME TIME
(*russian startled swearings)
"Blyat dafuq youre doing BLYAT"
((*note from a russian translator))
"BLYAT YOP TVOYU MAT' BLYAT WHO FCKING DOES THAT"
"HOW?!"
What?
*chuckles* What?
I'm Sorry
I'm gonna have to ask for an explanation of
what the heck was going on there.
Did he grade that girls test...
... by drilling it with a drill?
(Well yes of course, who doesn't these days)
*struggling to understand the slav culture*
Just anotha day in Russia!
SLAV
REVIEW
Just anotha day in Russia!
Thats honestly really cute
Russian cats everybody
Is that real?
(Sure why not pewds they can be if you want)
Are they actually squatting?
The slavs have taken feline form.
Very Niiice
Just dress those cats up in addidas...
And you're good to go.
(russian surprised swearing)
OMG
He's gonna hurt someone.
OMG x2
Turn off the thing please.
You're gonna cut someone.
(Chuckling:)  Jesus Christ.
OMG ver. 3.0
He got 'em!
He got 'em! x2
Just a normal day in Russia!
OH JESUS CHRIST.
*beep beep*
OH. MY. GAWD.
JUST A NORMAL DAY IN RUSSIA EVERYONE!
Look at that guy!
Oh my GOD
Ah jeez.
Just.
Just..
Just...
*drum roll please*
And it's a whamen.
Is anyone surprised?
*Desperate attempt to not get demonetized again*
Anyone remember the Cold War?
Never forghetti.
Get ready Dmitry
pew
pew pew
pew pew pew
WHOAAA(pew pew)AAAAAA!
OMG
DMITRY!
That's innovation
right there
That takes skill and cunningness
Whatever that means...
in russian: "Honestly, i really think, I hope
Headphones down in 3
Headphones down in 2
Headphones down in 1
*BIG CRASH*
Jesus.
oh my god
What is that?
Okay?
((russian hysterical laughter))
HOW ARE THEY LAUGHING?!
(More turkey laughs)
Your kitchen
IS ON FIRE!!!
Jesus Christ
I  d...
GodDamned (byets?)
God Damn
Cursed Footwear
AIDS!
AIDS MY FAVORITE BRAND (me too pewds!)
Dude uhh.
WHAT ARE THOSE?
Just rockin' those AIDS man!
What can I say?
Dude! Are those the latest AIDS?
God Damn they look sick
They look FIRE.
RUSSIAN
GAMER
CHAIR.
Improvise. Adapt. Overcome.
BUT CAN IT DO THIS?
I don't... I don't think so.
Russians
Try again.
This is why you need to pay $399
BLYAT TVOYU SUKA
How did this happen?
How do you get in this situation?
((in russian: GET OUT OF THERE))
((GET OUT OF THERE ALREADY BLYAT))
Oh Gawd x2
Oh Gawd x3
Oh Gawd x4
Oh Gawd x5
OK
Everyone made it safe
Everyone made it out safe
ok
ALRIGHT
G R E A T
Jesus Christ
How is anyone alive?
Russians are you okay?
((note from russian translator: (｡•́︿•̀｡) ))
What is that?
What is that? x2
in russian: Well, this is nice
Did they replace a wheel with a log?
Improvise!
Adapt
Overcome
Hey look!
It's another log replacement!
(Take off the brake!)
((astonished russian swearing))
You know what, as dangerous and
life-threatening as it seems to be
AT LEAST they're having fun, you know
"Russia is just big multiplayer game... with crazy mods"
"I saw lots of cars, but not the same number of wheels"
(Playing Nataliya Mogilevskaya - Pol'ubi menya takoy)
what's happening
Oh my gah
Ooh that's great
Oh the whole car is tilting
You can't tell if this is
sad or hillarious
I don't
I got so many conflicting emotions while watching this
in russian: "Look, it's an actual cat getting out"
HEY
They have furries in Russia
I didn't know
Who woulda thought
You lost some ??? today, Russia
I'm sorry
((But you seemed so excited at first))
"Come on!"
"Come on, come on!"
(Are you stupid or something)
No STOP just STOP
STOP USING IT
((Come on Felix))
STOP
((Man up))
STOOP
Please STOP
(but thas how we fish! how u gonna fish when its -45C?)
Ah Jesus Christ
"I'm not gonna feed you out of my hands, eat it like that"
"Here, eat it"
"BiTch"
(lmao)
"Well, thats how have it here"
I was gonna say, in Sweden a lot of times we joke that
to foreigners we just have polar bears everywhere and we ride them to work
But in Russia
It seems like it's actually the case
(no we do not ride bears)
(we just have them as pets))
"Take out the seal"
"Take out the safety pin"
Take it and put it on the table
"Press it"
"tada"
"And thats how you put out THE FIRE IN YOUR SOUL!
Wait, as that VODKA?
(duh)
Oh it's VODKA
Jesus Christ!
Russia, STOP tryna hide vodka in everything
Let's put it out
By pouring alcohol on it
Fantastic
WHERE ARE ALL THE WHEELS IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE ARE ALL THE WHEEHAHALS
"Hey, brudda"
Oh gah it's, oh yeah I've seen
"Brother"
"Wake up brother"
"Hey brother"
Aww, depressed pigeon
"This is so sad"
(Alisa play Деспасито)
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
"Another day in Russia" everyone
U slav u lose, whatever it was
I hope you had fun
If you did
Smash like, it will help out the channel, I very much appreciate it
It helps me a lot, as well
To push through
So I can watch more funny videos, for you guys
I know, it's tough work
Goodbye
(bye, Felix, love u from Russia <3)